ladies and gentlemen honorable laureates
their colleagues their students ladies
and gentlemen this year's Nobel Prize in
Chemistry is all about outstanding
imagination creativity and breaking new
grounds completely new grounds in
science fundamental science and as you
know the price is awarded to three
venerable gentlemen jean-pierre Subash
surfaces torrid and been failing her for
the design and synthesis of molecular
machines the world's tiniest smallest
machines you can have ever imagined so
you just think about that for a moment
about the machines what is a machine
well you can define it as as a type of
construction composed of different
components different parts working
together and designed to produce some
kind of useful output as a response of
well typically energy input all these
parts they have to be very very
carefully designed they have to be built
they have to be assembled they probably
need to be able to move relative each
other while interacting with one another
this task is quite hard to achieve
already at the macroscopic level but
just imagine how what a what a very
challenging task it is to to do this at
the molecular level you know you can
only in principle only see these
structures through very very very
sophisticated microscopes nevertheless
our three laureates
they took on this I was a rather wild
and formidable challenge of realizing
this kind of machine like structures at
the molecular level and this challenge
not only required exceptional as
exceptional creativity in chemical
synthesis in the design of chemical
molecules and the Laureus all the
lawyers had to develop fundamental new
methodology to achieve this but it also
required that they developed solutions
for the controlled motion of these
structures these constructions to
actually do to result in machine like
function so you will hear a lot more of
these very spectacular structures and
constructions that three lawyers have
have have made during these years in its
very short dip so they will tell us much
more about their adventures and their
journey towards functional molecular
machines and so I will now introduce our
first speaker and it's actually a little
bit fitting that the name of our first
speaker professor of Sauvage reminds us
of the quite wild and difficult
challenge this has been ok Shapira
Sauvage was born in 1944 in paris in
france he moved around quite a bit when
he was young but finally ended up in
Strasbourg where he received he was
awarded a PhD in 1971 from the
University of Strasbourg in northeastern
France and now he is a Meritus professor
at the University of Strasbourg and also
emeritus director research at the
National Center for scientific research
or CNRS in France so but I want to
welcome professor Sauvage up to the
stage
[Applause]
Thank You Olaf well well let me start
that by saying that it's a it's an
incredible honor you know to be here
today and to deliver one of the three
Nobel lectures in chemistry I mean this
is something I never dreamed of in the
past as you say and we'd like to thank
the the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences for selecting our epic
molecular machines and also for
selecting me as one of the other heads
with the two other nerds who are in a
way good friends of mine you so let me
start I will also talk about chemical
topology today because chemical topology
it's really to some extent a precursor
at least for my group the precursor to
molecular machines and which is I mean
certainly something important just a bit
of history I think history of science is
very important you know and I I deeply
regret that very often it's neglected in
our teaching chemical topology started
many years ago in 1961 by a very nice
publication co-authored by dr. fresh and
dr. Wasserman and these two people these
two scientists were working in industry
so in a way it's kind of paradoxical
that Bell Laboratories was financing
research and something which looks
completely exotic in a way and very far
from applications and fish and wasserman
just published the discussion
there were no experiments nothing in
there just a discussion on chemistry and
topology and it was the first time that
those two words actually chemical and
topology were associated and unless I
think it is a very important paper
because for the first time
chemists I could see that some molecular
graphs of some graphs can be a planar or
non planar although the the molecules
could contain exactly the same sets of
chemical bonds and atoms I think that
was the very beginning and now
experimentally I think the most
important contribution comes from
Germany from Freiburg in Germany very
very close to my own cities was worth
maybe 80 kilometres south east and in
particular professor shin and his his
boss professor between house legendary
organic chemist of a saluting house they
published a paper in 1964 in ungallant
Hemi Peter I hope you are sensitive to
that and it was a very important paper
historical paper that was the the
synthesis of the first catenin to
catenate consisting of two interlocking
rings it was brilliant work very very
elegant but in terms of let's say
practical outcome it was not so
spectacular because they need in many
many steps and the the overall yield of
the process were certainly very modest
and so the people at the time were very
impressed by the work but they were not
so enthusiastic trying to make a turn
ends in themselves using strategies
similar to those published in this
historical paper and for some years
maybe 10 15 20 years the field became
less active and at the beginning of the
80s when my group starting in this field
it was really a dormant field so nobody
was basically nobody was working in this
field and professor Hanson in one of his
letters suggested that we we may or we
are invited in a way to talk about the
story behind the discovery and I think
it is a very good in a very good point
you know it's an important statement how
did you get the ideas how did you start
the work and that's what I'm going to
explain you so at the the beginning of
the 80s when I started my own group I
was very much interested in in organic
photochemistry trying to split water the
water molecule to h2 and o2 and of
course it was a big big challenge which
is still a challenge today and there
were many important transition metal
complexes which were expected to be
important and interesting in relation to
water splitting and I had done some work
in this field in particular with my
supervisor
Gemma Helene and the the main complex
was a ruthenium complex and ruthenium is
very expensive and we showed that copper
the copper complex could be practically
more interesting and if applications
were expected copper would be certainly
more attractive than lithium and Dave
McMillan spent a year in Strasbourg on
sabbatical leave from Purdue University
and we were making some strange molecule
strange to him we like to be simple
to us and when he third is molecule
which we had made in my group he said we
must collaborate we are for the
physicists and for the chemists you are
molecule makers in a way and so let's
collaborate and we collaborated we made
a copper complex of this type containing
two diphenyl fin and Rollins so this is
financially this is jargon you can
forget about it but there are two
nitrogen atoms here which are able to
interact with copper so we we made this
complex and it turned out to be very
exciting in terms of photochemical
properties in terms of photo physics
it had a long large time for its excited
state it could transfer electrons it
could do many many very interesting
things so that was the very beginning
because if you look carefully at the
structure you realize that if you
connect this point to that point
separately this point to that other
point here you make a cut a name very
very simple let me do it with a better
laser pointer if you start from here you
will connect this point to that point
separately this point to that other
point and you have a catenin and so we
decided to in a way to stop Mijares in
organic photochemistry and we jumped
towards organic synthesis and towards
the making of katha names and I think
the the main requirement was to be
experimental II able to jump from in
organic photochemistry to organic
synthesis and at the time I had a very
good friend christian de sica
and this very good friend was a CNS
researcher in another group and she
decided to come and work with me so
basically we started the the group
almost together
and she was a great organic chemist
fantastic synthetic chemist and thanks
to her all the work I will now discuss
could be done so we published the first
paper in 1983 it's here 1983 in a let's
say with an oblique good quality journal
but not a top journal not a high-impact
journal and we published it in French
that could be surprising we published it
in French because we had a feeling that
it was a perhaps it will become an
important paper I mean it's pretty easy
to understand what it means you know new
very familiar molecule the molecule they
made material catenin do I need to
translate so that was the very first
paper and I will now explain you a
little bit more in detail how we we
proceeded so we you know after this
first paper this first paper we really
generalize the concepts which we call a
transition metal templated principle so
we will use a transition metal as let's
say the the template in species able to
gather various organic farm ins to
orient them in a three-dimensional space
and to maintain them in a given geometry
so it's quite easy here we start from
the transition metal centre we have two
organic farm ins able to interact with
the metal we generate what we used to
call the end to iron structure we make a
ring here we make a ring here and of
course at the end of the day we obtain a
cattle name very very simple we could
also be a little bit more sophisticated
we start from a ring which contains a
coordinating fragment
here we mix with the transition metal
the open chain fragment which is able to
interact with the metal and so we will
obtain this assembly and finally we make
a ring from here to here using a GG
fragment and we used to call that the
gathering and threading strategy if you
like I think nowadays we will see the
assembling and unthreading strategy just
a brief look at the molecules so we
start from the molecule a very simple
molecule again containing this building
block here the financial in with its two
nitrogen atoms just in passing this is
not came true this is Indian ink drawing
you know very old hurring historical
drawing and in a way I think it can
complete with control so we take two
such molecules copper one will generate
the end point intermediate as I said
before this compound can be made at the
ten gram scale within a couple of days
so this is very very easy we do not even
isolate these species we go on and now
we proceed to the double cyclisation
reaction we take a long organic
fragments no need to discuss the
methodology we will interconnect those
two points here and separately those two
other points at the back so this is
exactly what we have seen on the
strategy Freud and we can make let's say
half a gram of such a molecule which is
a catenary now we have indeed our two
interlocking rings at a central copper
one metal here in
the yield was not very good but I mean
it was so straightforward that in a way
changed completely
the the situation and I think it changed
also the the way chemists were looking
at Catalans so they were not completely
exotic species they were not completely
impossible to make species they became
all of a sudden accessible molecules we
were lucky enough to crystallize those
fishes so this is the copper complex
catenin you see the XY structure which
is really kind of a picture of the
molecule a real picture of the molecule
I can move it so that maybe you can see
it better the copper 1 Center is green
here in passing this is ridiculous
because all these complexes are deep red
but we had a grain a green ball here to
put and if you deem it early the system
rearranges completely and this is
reversible and once you have rearranged
the system you have a very open
structure the two rings can glide freely
within the other you have very little
control over the geometry of these
species but it's a complete
metamorphosis and this is the way we
call the process a metamorphosis so this
being said I should say that we became
interested in cattle names for several
reasons but probably the main reason was
that chata names or and knots so this is
a no this is a Catalina slightly more
complex chatter name than the one we
have seen there are ubiquitous in nature
in DNA in proteins in viruses even we
have no time to see so many examples but
here just DNA
forms beautiful topologies and and
continuously I mean it's not something
which is really exceptional it is
something which is routine so a bit of
history so there were of course a lot of
interest figured by the synthesis of
cattle names I would like to refer to
the beautiful work of our good friend
Fraser
who really blew up the field in a way so
we started as a modest small group in
France and I think basically there was
an explosion thanks to him and his group
in the UK a Chris hunter and Fritz
factly they use hydrogen bonding as
assembling entities Makarov Fujita added
also beautiful work based on the
Palladium nitrogen bond which is labile
and thermo dynamically stable and I
think I stopped in 1994 and after that
there were too many contributors so that
there will be a to long list you know
but there is beautiful work which is
still done now and I would like to thank
all the people who joined the team so to
say the worldwide team of cattle names
and hotel chains and other species just
in passing
there was a pioneer hero she Aquino at
Tokyo University in Sendai who also
published a beautiful piece of work with
cyclodextrins and transition metals just
before we started the molecular
machinery part of my short lecture a few
topologies which have been made in my
group you know mostly for the the
challenge that making these typologies
represented so that was the
system cat inane a free cat inane very
simple topology in 8687 we had the
east-west structure in 87 and that was
the cover page of Angewandte Chemie and
the trifle not was very very challenging
it took us years and years but thanks to
christian batricia shaker
you know we succeeded and the the ee
interlocking catenin which is
represented here i was mostly the work
of shah jahan even gotten another great
synthetic chemist and now let's talk
about molecular machines shortly and
just referring to biology because
biology is really a source of
inspiration for chemists we knew that in
biology molecular machines are
everywhere again you cannot think of any
important biological process not using
motor proteins so molecular machines ATP
synthase is an example and there were
some beautiful work done in in many
places and ATP synthase and the
understanding of its function and the
way it works
kinnison is also an important very
important molecular machine with a small
protein which can walk on a rail the
rail being a microtubule in the cell so
there are many many many examples
what about cattle names and hotel chains
so cattle names and hotel chains are
certainly very attractive in this
respect you can quite easily figure out
that ring can glide along the axis on
which it has been threaded from position
let's say to another position and and
vice versa go back to the original
position
a ring could be hopefully able to rotate
about the axis or again in a Catalina
ring
perhaps I can glide and rotate within
the other ring so very attractive
structures for making molecular machines
just I know it's a very dangerous line
because I may be in the audience there
are people who had done some beautiful
work in the field of molecular machines
but I tried to collect you know the some
of the of the names of the most
successful groups in the field of
molecular machines based on interlocking
and cattle names and high-tech science
and Fraser Stewart and his group
vincenzo Barzani actually ha ha ha da I
mean they have done beautiful work David
Lee who was a student with Frazer and
many many other groups nowadays using
cattle names and Hort accents to make
molecular machines so now I will just
show you what we did in Strasbourg in
relation to molecular machines so the
idea was quite simple it was to take a
cat named relatively simple cat inane
and to move it and the way we did was
the following so we have copper one year
and you know that copper has two
oxidation states copper one and copper
to copper one life to be four coordinate
it likes to be surrounded by four
nitrogen atoms so as for it to be
tetrahedrally surrounded by nitrogen
atoms copper two-plus on the other hand
is much more demanding copper two-plus
likes to be five coordinate or even six
coordinate Cisco renate with an
octahedral geometry with young
distortion of five coordinates and so
now we will play with that the
requirements of copper one are not at
all the same as those of copper two
let's start from copper one here we have
a very happy copper one and the copper
one iron can be oxidized to copper to
copper two plus the discover two plus is
still four coordinate tetrahedral
surrounding and this is not satisfactory
at all for copper two so the system will
relax so as to found a more satisfactory
situation in terms of thermodynamics
which means that the ring will glide
here the the three nitrogen atoms which
are here will replace the two nitrogen
atoms which are here originally and the
ring will glide half-term so as to
generate a happy copper two so copper
two is now five coordinate it is it
forms a very stable complex and nothing
moves anymore apart from Brownian motion
of course and this is very present also
to monitor for the people who did the
work we start from a deep right complex
we obtain a deep green complex you have
to be patient it takes a minute or so
and after the deep green complex you
obtain a yellowish complex not a very
nice color by the way and if you go back
you exceeded oh sorry you reduce you
inject an electron in the copper 2
Center you generate a five coordinated
copper one and these five coordinate
copper one is a it's very unhappy and
the complex will rearrange so that the
ring will glide again and you regenerate
the starting state of the molecule so
that was the first molecular machine in
our group it's not really a rotation
it's a PM wetting system
I insist from the very beginning we have
no control over directionality and if
you want to to know more about rotary
motors of course you have to read all
the literature published by the group of
them I have a simple video ok which I
will show you it's a video which was
made by a student of mine who is now in
the Netherlands so we have copper one we
have here a financially with its two
nitrogen atoms and here we have the
second financially in here so this is
copper one with four nitrogen atoms now
we will abstract an electron it's a blue
electron if you noticed and the blue
electron with being removed we have
copper to the system rearranges and you
have now five coordinate copper two you
can re-inject the electron not the same
of course and you reform the four
coordinate complex and I think the
beauty of the system is that we can do
it as many times as you like with
molecules of course you can do it as
many times as you like in silico but
with molecules - everything is perfectly
clean perfectly quantitative so that
it's a nice very reversible and clean
system so I will have very limited time
to talk about molecular muscles but let
me just show you the principle so we
wanted to make a molecular system which
is reminiscent of molecular muscles in
the sense that contracting or elongating
molecular muscles means gliding
filaments so you have filaments will
which glide along one another so you
have the relaxed form of the muscle here
the contracted form of the muscle and
you see that those filaments simply
glide and what we did was to design and
make a molecule it was a relatively
complex complicated molecule we made a
molecule with behaved in exactly the
same way this is a hot taxane dimer and
what we could show is that we can
contract it and we send another signal
to the molecule we can elongate it and
contract it and this can be done you
know many times we have no time I assume
for two minutes thank you it's very
accurate so we have no time for
discussing you know the work in detail
and I will skip all that some very
important slide I think will be the the
slide gathering the names and they of
the people we did the work at first I
would like to conclude this is my
conclusions long transition metals are
very important in our case you know we
were we are more coordination chemists
than supramolecular chemistry be honest
but transition metals played a very
important role in our chemistry they
allowed us to build the system using
templating principles so the transition
metal can gather and dispose the various
organic fragments around the metal in a
very well-defined and very wet
controlled way which allows to make
target molecules of interest and due to
the presence of the transition metal in
the molecule the system has interesting
electrochemical properties and
photochemical properties and this is how
we could move the molecules or let's say
set some parts of the molecules in
motion
such as
two or three states swinging cations we
have seen the two two states
swinging cat inane molecular shuttles we
made a wing flapping for taxing and
contrast contractile and extensible
molecular systems reminiscent of muscles
I mean stop at this stage let me just
say one world of the the French system
you know the French system I'm not sure
it's perfect but there are good good
points in it provided you adapt your
policy to the French system it can be
efficient and in particular we have
permanent people working in our groups
and we were working in my group as a
group of permanent people I was
considered the leader of the group but
the other permanent people were friends
most of the time some of them were of my
generation and these are the people you
know working with me not all of them at
the same time but Christian Charles
chauvel who is now in digital color with
now completely retired very hard with a
professor in our university and some
younger younger members CNN has members
or assistant professors so John McCain
passed away in a in an aircraft accident
in a crash many years ago so that was
also a very bad moment and I have a
special suit for my two first PhD
students Pascal Manu and Hama repair
because I think at the beginning you
know it's important to work with very
motivated students and they were indeed
very motivated I'm not going to read the
list of people who participated in this
project or adventure and contains what
explains our not
just to have the work on the muscles was
mostly carried out by the Spanish
postdoc incredibly active Spanish
postdoc Maria Consuela Jimenez and the
work on the swinging catenae in the very
first molecular machine that was mostly
the work of liver area finally let me
thank my University and the CNS also
which had a very important contribution
the European communities you know
without the European communities I don't
think we would have been able to do as
much work as we did and the the regime
as us which is around Strasbourg my city
we have a foundation which was also very
helpful my new Institute because they
had to move five years ago after I
retired officially by this Northwestern
University Thank You Fraser from
arranging for me to spend several years
part-time in a fantastic environment I
would like to thank my supervisor when I
was a postdoc in Oxford Malcolm Green a
great organometallic chemist the two
most influential teachers get oversaw
and removals finally of course my wife
she has been always been very supportive
and this was also true for our sons
Union and I would also like to thank the
two other low hates Fraser and men
because without their great
contributions I wouldn't be here today
thank you
[Applause]